my Wow
hello Christianity is all in you
[music]
and this desire to defeat Russia
today has acquired, as we know, very
dangerous forms,
we pray to the Lord that he will enlighten those
madmen and help them understand that any
desire to destroy Russia will mean the
end of the world
[music]
Today we  we know
that there are very big threats to the peace of
our country Yes, and to the whole
human race
because some crazy people have
appeared
not a single
enemy who has always emerged
victorious that they can
either be defeated in the current conditions or, as they
say now, reformatted, that is,
impose on them certain values ​​that
cannot even be called values
so that they are like
everyone else and obey those who have the power to
control most  peace
[music]